So
when when we train
we actually have to train
uh that means we have a goal in mind. It
should be the next thing you need uh in
the progression of your skill and
everything we do should be oriented
towards the attainment of that skill.
That is training. Okay. Uh practicing is
when you're just doing something
uh over and over again. Um we don't want
to practice. Okay. So, as I mentioned on
the thread,
um
you don't want to accumulate bad reps
because that's what you get good at.
You're only good at what you repeat. Um
the universe doesn't know the difference
between that was a bad rep or this was a
good rep. just reinforces whatever you
were doing. Okay, this is one reason why
again at the micro level uh if I'm
constantly daily um practicing
contestation, I get pretty freaking good
at contestation. And so I spend more
time practicing contestation, less time
practicing non-contestation. It's going
to be very hard to get good at
non-contestation. All right. Hence all
the four disciplines, hence the bedrock
practices because they fill up their
your day with the problem of
non-contestation.
We're not unconsciously or consciously
repeating more reps in non-contest in
contestation. Okay. So likewise, when
we're doing this, we can't we can't keep
doing the wrong stuff. So, as I've
mentioned before, when I teach shooting
to people and they will not do the
fundamentals as I'm telling them, we
just done. We're we're done because
you're just wasting ammunition right now
and you're getting good at doing crappy
Okay. Uh it's a lot different in
law enforcement because we have, you
know, we have like that paramilitary
organization and we get to and get in
their face, you know, and they go,
"What's what's the matter? You got a
problem with me? All right. you
eyeballing me now and all that kind of
stuff. Why don't you just do what I say?
What you got a character issue? You
know, okay, we're not going to do that.
But what we do is like what coaches do
and coaches will reel you in and get you
and dial you in. Okay, your good coaches
like Tristan, I told you like he's
playing with that that one coach, Coach
Reed, and he needs Tristan to get to
another level of play. And it's this
combination somewhere in between law law
enforcement, paramilitary, and uh you
know your your good coach who's going,
we're going to work on what we need to
work on. Okay. But he did eventually
make Tristan go, "Hey, Trist, you're
like a black hole. Tristan, you're a
black hole." Which because he wants him
to pass the ball uh when he drives and
three, he gets a threeon-one. He wants
him to find the open man. And he's like,
"Tristan, you're a black hole." And he
kept saying, he's Tristan, come over
here. Come over here. Tell me, coach,
I'm a black hole. Coach, I'm a black
hole. Okay, got the idea? All right. So,
we're we have to float somewhere around
in there. But I want you to be very
conscious of what we're doing and why
we're doing so that you can go home and
work on this stuff with your people.
Okay? So, what were we feeling in this
drill?
Anything at all? Bring it to a conscious
level. Yes.
Okay. Um, let's see. Let's go.
Okay. Stop. Go back
again.
Freeze. Okay. Is there any pressure on
you right now?
Just a tiny bit. Everyone understand how
low the the spinal displacement is right
now.
Does your pinky normally do that?
Okay. So, probably not. But there's
already tension in the tendon. Do do you
see that? But we're not we're not aware
of it. Okay. So, we'll do we'll bring
some awareness to it.
Okay. And again, real quick from
yesterday as he's driving, drive, drive,
drive, drive. Um, my hand shape, what's
on the other side of the grip in no way
can maintain positional integrity.
Does everyone understand that? What's on
the other side of his grip is not
helping
my wrist stay in space in the same
place. It's not possible. It doesn't
have a a jet engine that's pulling me
that way. Do you understand? Yet in my
unconscious contestation,
I am bringing flexion into this that has
nothing to do
with that. Do you got it? Does that make
sense? Okay. Here's though. Extend that
idea.
I'm here like that. That was not
necessary. This flexion was not
necessary. And what I want to put before
you is
this forearm flexion is not necessary.
So think about it.
What does your forearm muscles do
mechanically? Yes, it it closes my
fingers.
Is the ability to close or open my
fingers have anything to do with my
wrist staying in the same vertical
plane? It doesn't. Do Do you get it? But
yet I flexed it. I flexed them. Okay.
Does that make sense? Okay. Now, what
does my bicep and tricep muscles do to
bend my arm? Extend my arm.
Does that have is anyone trying to bend
my arm or stop me from extending my arm
in this drill? No. But I'm flexing them.
Okay. So,
what's happening is I enter into the
contestation and I start overall flexing
my muscles. that tension comes in and it
doesn't have anything to do. So my my
hand has nothing to do with that
ability. My forearm has nothing to do
with that ability.
My tricep bicep has nothing to do drive.
What is keeping that in space at a
minimum? What I want you to understand
it's not any of these muscles.
I have to risk releasing them. Okay,
does that make sense? All right, so
you're going to do the following drill.
You're going to uh drive. Drive. He has
to drive. I am going to shake my hand.
I'm going to wiggle my fingers.
Okay. I'm going to shake my whole arm.
Don't go so high because he'll lose or
so low he'll lose the angle. Try to stay
in there.
You'll realize if you can. My shoulders
don't have anything to do with it
either.
Okay, let's see what we feel. You may
feel like, "No way. I don't want to do
that." You, if you get sensitive enough,
you may feel like that's where I feel
I'm going to lose it. Okay.
Let's bring consciousness to that
feeling. Okay. All right. Try it. How
hard were you pushing? He's very hard.
Okay, you can see him slipping off the
ground. Okay, go.
Pay attention to your mind. What your
mind is doing as you're doing all these
drills.
Push, push, push hard.
Don't Don't bring your wrist. My My
wrist isn't moving out of the the
vertical plane.
So, I'll try to be on this. Let me move
you a little. I'll be on this uh line
here. You see the grip? Okay. I'm not
going in and out. I'm leaving it in
space.
It's staying in that space. Okay. All
right. Try it again.
You're going to get tired, okay? You're
you're our trainer. We need you to push.
If you need two hands, push with two
hands. Doesn't matter.
Change partners.
So we have to uh Watch
this this drill.
You got to be careful with this drill.
So I g I give you caveats and just like
the coach the coach is setting you up.
Do it like this so we get the result we
want. Okay. So when I shook my arms,
what did I say not to do?
not to make too big a deviation. The
reason why is push. And you can see how
you can get your power into it, right?
Keep pushing. You're going to get tired.
Keep pushing. But once I go like here,
she can't ever get her power into it. Do
you understand? So I don't I'm not
trying to take force off of her. Uh,
does that make sense? So when I'm
shaking, she's she's driving. You could
use two hands. Okay. Um, you can stand
up.
Yeah, I I'm not trying to do an Iikido
delevering of her. Do Do you understand?
So, I'm I am feeling her. So, I'm not
going to go and then she can't ever get
her legs into it. Okay? So, I'm I have
to stay where I feel the urge to flex.
Do do you Otherwise, I can't work on the
problem. Okay? All right. So, try it
again.
Let's stand up.
And again, Virginia, how how how hard
are you? Were you trying to drive with
your legs? Right. Okay. It's It's hard.
No, the the the nugget is sitting down.
Give your knees a break, Virginia.
At a minimum, find your
conscious level of your flexion.
should be loose.
Okay, let's I know we'll do some more
coaching. So, switch rolls.
You're going to go, Rio.
All right. Okay.
We had some coaching yesterday and
freeze freeze. Rio,
where
where does this deviate from yesterday?
The elbow bend. Do you see that? And
again on your on when you submit your
videos, I constantly say, right, okay,
so when he when he bends his arm to this
degree,
in order to keep his hand the wrist grab
positionally in place,
he's going to have to activate his
triceps. Do do you see? Because now he
is tasking himself with got to keep my
arm extended. Does that make sense?
Okay. So, this is where the coach comes
in. So, we're here and bend your arm
again. Do you see? Okay. And I expose
that to him. Does that make sense? Okay.
I'm not going to sit here. Go and let
him do that. And then I hang out here.
Do you feel that difference? See how See
his relaxation there? What was I told to
do as UK the trainer push?
Okay. So, you got to watch this. It's
it's a it's a modern Iikido thing,
right? You're so used to cooperating,
but we're This is not We want a contest
so that I know how to non-contest. Does
that make sense? So, you have to pay
attention. The instructor said, "Get up
and drive. Use two hands if you want.
Hey, you don't have enough power. Get up
and use your legs." Yeah. You got to
pull and deduce. What's he What's he
want from me? Okay. All right. Try it
again.
That didn't take very long to expose,
Andrew.
And then you feel what you feel. Okay. I
want you to bring your consciousness to
that level.
finger tension.
Derek, use two hands.
Feel
where you feel your tension, your
flexion. It might you might not be
conscious of it till it actually hurts,
but prior to the hurting, there was a
flexion. Does Does that make sense? So,
okay, I didn't feel the flexion, but I
ah ah that's seizing up. That's
fatiguing. That's cramping. That
actually hurts my old injury.
Okay, note it and try to feel the
flexion that happened right before that.
Okay, once you feel the flexion, I don't
want you to go to the pain part. Just
Okay, let go. Get get out of the
technique. We're just trying to bring it
to conscious level. Okay, go.
Fix your head, Chris.
Okay, go back.
All right, freeze. Don't move. Don't
move. Okay, no pressure, though.
Where is the deviation from yesterday's
training?
No, that that's not important. We didn't
even talk about that yesterday. Not so
important here.
Do you do you see that? Do you see the
angling? Okay. That the shoulders are
this one's forward. Do you got it? Okay.
Now, why
there's something else?
He's He's obviously trying not to be
turned. Do you see that? So, he
contested against the turn that he felt.
Okay. Now go to what's making him
turnable
because when we contest we start the
whole rippling
right the pebble in the pond just as we
we have the non-contestation and it
ripples out the contestation ripples out
too. So you're going to see uh where
this is being exacerbated by something
that had that he did from the very
start.
No. Come and look around the body.
What were the instructions yesterday?
Where is his elbow related to his
shoulder? is outside the shoulder. Do
you see that? And that generates
this
this. Do you see? So, let me in. See his
elbows out out here. And so, I if if I
just push because I gripped on the
outside. I didn't grip here. Make a
fist. I'm not gripping here.
There has to be a slight Yes. But yes.
So, you'll feel it now. You see? Okay.
And again, my coach should have just
been able to do that. But you, what's
happening is when you're down, you feel
your own flexion
and you feel like you're doing
something.
You need to do as UK the same thing he's
doing. He is letting energy go down. I
let energy go down. And that's what's
moving. And he could feel that shoulder
biting now. Okay. Does that make sense?
Okay. Okay. So, let's have another team
go. I don't care who. Go. Watch
down.
Okay. Stop.
You see that? See the angle again? We're
already in the contestation. Do Do you
see that? Trying to get Trying to get
here. Okay.
There's already
a weakness in the torso in the in the in
the spine. So don't move. You don't
move. Now let go.
Do you see it? Okay. So your first thing
is you're relax you're relaxing,
right? But what were we told yesterday?
Releasing is not relaxing. I can't go
like this. What were we told in Zazen?
My spine has to do
reaching up. You can't. If you relax,
it doesn't do it. So, you have no energy
going through your spine. Okay? And
which you can expose. Okay? All right.
So, my point here is that all these
things are showing up, but I'm just not
conscious of them. Just like I'm not
conscious of the habitual flexion I have
all day against the gravity that's
working on me. You see? And I never feel
the rebounding force or the pressing up
of the earth. I never feel those forces.
Okay? But imagine in your art
that's one with the universe. We're
supposed to be able to feel those
forces. And if I can feel them, I can
use them. You see? And that's where and
if I can use them then I don't have to
use these other forces that make me
waste energy and things like that. Okay.
So let's I'll get to a conscious level
so we can answer the question again.
Where's my flexion? Okay. All right. Go
for it.
And we already know release is not
relaxed.
The spine is reaching upward.
We want our elbow inside our outer rim.
Not too much bend on that arm. Rio,
extend it more. Extend it more. If you
need them to do less pressure, do less
pressure. If you need more pressure, do
more pressure.
If I bend my arm, I'll I have to use my
tricep. So, just a slight bend.
Too much arm bend.
Good. Coach each other.
Look for hand flexion. Look for shoulder
pushing in. Look for the biceps.
Too much bicep. Extend more
and leave your hand in that position.
Okay.
Where are you flexing
against the spinal displacement?
Where where do you feel it? Bicep,
shoulder, hand. Right. Where do you feel
it?
Okay. Where do you feel it? Okay. Got
Got it. All right. What we have to do is
when we feel that tension is we have to
release it like in zen. Okay.
That is a macro version of the gravity
that is working on us in zazen. We just
made everything grosser. Okay. Like in
the face of that gravity, I release
tension
in some way. I don't ever fall. I get to
stay in this mountain shape. Okay. Same
thing's going to happen here.
But it's very hard to believe in it.
Okay.
So
I will make the following point.
Shape does not matter.
Okay. But shape will assist you at the
beginning because of the space
requirement. Okay. So, um, as I
demonstrated yesterday, he's he's
driving and it kind of looks like I'm
doing skeletal alignment. Do do you
understand? Okay. But I'm not. He He can
Where's the skeletal alignment?
That should go way back here. This
should start to burn.
Does that make sense? There's He's
pushing. There's no skeletal alignment.
You can move just as freely. If I to
flex,
everything starts to burn. Okay.
Same thing we were doing yesterday. He's
driving
this. The posture that I'm in
doesn't isn't push isn't necessary at
all. Staying still is not necessary
either. Okay.
So the takeaway here is the form is not
important
but we'll use form to help cultivate the
faith we need to let go of the muscle
tension and eventually the skeletal
alignment. Okay.
The other reason for understanding form
and this is very important is
energetically
form is not important.
Marshially form is very important.
If for example
energetically this works
partially this does not work. Okay.
So, for marshall reasons, I do want to
understand how to organize my body.
Okay? And this is going to get you in
the ballpark.
One,
never let your elbow go outside your
shoulder.
Okay? The adding to yesterday's class,
if my hand tension has nothing to do
with my wrist positional integrity, my
forearm tension has nothing to do with
it. My tricep, so uh come on over, Rio.
Okay. Uh he's driving and you squeeze.
Is there mushy as hell? like like uh my
mom was she was 80. Okay. Like mom gets
a muscle, right? It's very mushy. It has
nothing to do with positional integrity.
Where would you say
the positional integrity is? It is. I
know it's not here. It's not here. It's
not here.
What if this moves?
Do you understand? He goes
I lost it. It moved. Okay.
What's keeping this? Where does this
want to go? Is my shoulder going to blow
off and go backwards and that's why this
move? No. It rotates around my spine.
You see that? Okay.
That's why if I keep my spine reaching
the muscles that affect that
extension go also stop the rotation. The
shoulder becomes unified
uh and it's like
there's a board across my back. Okay.
The shoulders marshially are a very weak
point. A very weak point. Yes. lots of
movement, but lots of movement means
loss of structural integrity. Loss of
structural integrity is where energy
could leak out. Okay? Uh I was watching
a wrestling coach and they the athlete,
he's at Olympic level. the athlete made
a big deal out of natural movement
and he would do all those kind of um
what's that guy's name? Ido Portal.
Okay, if you've seen him um or they're
moving, you know, like they pretend
they're cats and they move like cats and
things. And it was supposed to translate
into he would be highly mobile in
wrestling. And later what happened is
that he was very prone to injury
um with that mobility because there was
a loss of st stability.
Um and what they ended up doing was
compound lifting him which which builds
uh structural integrity which we said
yesterday. Okay. Um where on those spine
alignment muscles? Okay. Those spine
alignment muscles are different from
these muscles.
I can barely feel them. That's part of
the problem. You see? And so I can
barely experience them. Um and so they
don't do they don't do the same thing to
my body, mind, to my consciousness when
I'm flexing my shoulders and my arms and
things like that. So you're going to
drive. I'm flexing and then I'll start
to release everything.
Okay? And I'm now relaxed. I don't feel
the he can't go. He's not going to push
me anywhere. And I don't feel the need
to hurry up and get out of this
situation. Okay. So, there is some
muscular use. They're very hard to
become aware of. I would imagine some of
them are even involuntarily controlled.
Okay? Meaning, if you go to flex, you're
going to flex the other muscles. If you
task yourself with just extension
kind of unconsciously you're using them.
Okay.
But that's what helped keeps the
shoulder in place. Go. And that's why
yesterday
I could keep the elbow in place because
it's the shoulder in place. If we go
here, it's the same thing. He he cannot
make that happen. Okay. And when I
understand what that's doing, I he's
driving. I can move and he can't do it.
And I can come back and he can't do
anything about it. Okay. So, it has
nothing to do with this. It has nothing
to do with this. Nothing to do with
this. It does have to do with this, but
not that here. And dealing with the
Marshall problem of a ball and socket
joint and learning how to stabilize it
to my core. Okay. All right. So, um,
here's what we're going to do to get us
in the ballpark. You're going to form la
gong. It looks like that.
There's a couple key things to note.
There's a cup in the middle of your palm
that you could pour water and it would
stay there. Okay. That cup though is not
formed by me curling my metacarpals.
The metacarpals, these bones in my hand
are extending
until I feel that tension came into the
forearm.
Dial it back. This hand shape
and the forearm tension is not there and
you get mushy arms. Okay,
it looks like that.
The next thing is the palm, that cup is
in skeletal alignment with your forearm,
with your elbow, with your shoulder. So,
he's here. What would be incorrect is my
fingers
are in alignment with the elbow. And you
don't want to do that. I'm going to
watch what I do. I'm going to move
laong into that elbow alignment. You see
where I'm at? Okay.
Boom. I'm here. The elbow's never
outside my shoulder.
Okay. And now I just have to figure out
how much extension is on the arm.
So, we did yesterday's drill. He stood
up.
And I want you just to bend over 90
degrees with your thumbs pointing
towards me.
And the natural bend in his arm is kata
dori. He's not going to extend his arms.
Extend your arms, please. That was
hyperextension. And he's not going to
hold them against gravity. Too much
bend. He just relaxes
that natural bend. He keeps come back
into position with that natural bend.
He fixes laong. He brings the elbow in
alignment with the shoulder.
He extends the spine to subconsciously
control those muscles that are given
spinal integrity.
and he now releases the tension that
he's feeling.
Okay, got it. All right, let's do it a
little differently. Put your arm with
your bend. Let's do this one.
That's not going to work. He's going to
want to extend against it. He puts his
elbow out. He's going to feel that
pressure and this weak point at this at
this part. He puts his hand here like
that. He's going to over rely on
skeletal alignment. And so he's going to
push that shoulder forward like he is.
See that? Okay. So, coach each other.
You all know what we're looking
elbow in. Okay. Shoulder square. Extend
the spine. It will unconsciously,
subconsciously flex the muscles we need
flex, releasing the other muscles we
don't want flex. All right. Go for it.
Coach each other.
If you can coach them, you can go back
home and train yourself.
You got you have to uh activate those
spinal muscles, Rio.
I'm sorry, Angelo,
but expose it to him. There it is. You
see the tilts? Okay. So, extend up. Pull
the lats down, but extend up. And watch
the head. Fix the lang.
Relax.
Keep extending the spine. Keep dropping
the chin.
And start to release the tension without
moving in space.
Good.
Activate the spinal muscles by zikin
zazen. Reach up with the spine.
Fixes laong alignment.
His
elbows out.
More extension.
Good. Good.
Okay. So, what I'm seeing is, and you
should be able to see. I'm the coach,
but I can see it. I want you to see.
Everyone's pushing a lot harder. Okay,
now give some faith. Make a faith wrist.
Leap off the edge of the cliff and start
releasing those muscle tensions wherever
you can now feel it. Okay. All right.
Try it. Go.
Get yourself in the ballpark and then
start releasing
the arm, the hand.
You can't release the spine.
Your spine keeps reaching up.
Yes. Very good, Angelo.
Tilt your your head.
Risk it. Let the tricep go. Extend a
little more. There you go. So you keep
that natural bend.
Anywhere
you can feel tension. Anywhere is good.
Release it.
More extension. Virginia on those arms.
You got to coach Virginia. Extend more.
Derek. Good.
Okay. You keep keep pushing. This hand
has nothing to do with anything. So
release that hand. Okay. Keep your chin
to pull on the spine with the crown of
the head.
Good. This chest has nothing to do with
anything. So, drop it. There you go.
Keep it.
No flexion here. Has nothing to do with
anything.
You got to extend more.
Okay.
Much better.
Uh, we'll go to two hands. So, it's same
exact thing. Careful, you're not out
here like that because what did you do
wrong? The elbows are outside. Do you
see that? And now partially here comes
the headbutt. Boom. Here. Elbows are
inside. Okay. Tries the headbutt.
Something's in the way right here. So,
two lang. You're here and you're doing
the same
releasing.
Okay, let's try it. Go.
Your hands can go outside your
shoulders. Your elbows cannot.
Fix your lang alignment. Not your
fingers. Your fingers are not in
alignment with your forearms. Your
fingers are not in alignment with your
forearms.
Try to release tension.
More extension.
Lengthen the spine. Fix your chin and
head.
Release tension where you're feeling it.
Long fix it.
Okay.
Question.
Okay. So, um,
is the is the shape important?
No. Okay. But it is when
when you're starting out. Okay. So, um,
but let's look at that a little
differently. Okay.
an opponent
mar so energetically shape not important
marshially
opponents will make shape important all
the time so an opponent will try to get
under you okay for example in this case
I don't want us to go into what I today
call tai chi land where you you're going
to do energetic solution for that
because the opponent experiences the
energetics
exactly like any external force. So
whatever you're doing energetically,
let's say so he can't get under me
energetically.
Um they just said continue to adapt and
it's very very fast. So this go to the
good taichi article and this is what I
said happened. what happens. I pointed
it out in the Sefue Nico video when he
was against the wrestler. That is just
what happens. And anybody who actually
takes the energetics into
um
you know another sport like wrestling or
boxing or MMA, you that's just what
happens. Anyone that tries to arrest
that 80 pound year old girl, that's what
you just learn. Okay? People adapt. Uh
that is the nature of resistance. Okay.
Um so let's deal with this a different
way because as your skill develops
you'll learn how to do this
energetically. But let's get to the a
more martial thing. Okay. So
we do kokiho,
right? And normally you'll go you'll do
something like that, right? Okay. Let's
just have you practice cokeho and and
see where we're at. Okay, go.
You can do the pin, you can do the
throw, it doesn't matter.
Okay.
So, uh, Rio, come on out.
Concentrically, I should practice
non-contestation all the way through.
So, energetically, we understood it. uh
meditatively we understood it we have to
understand it marshally as well so we
already mentioned from yesterday's class
I never actually push against that
person do I have the capacity to do it
and do I test for it like maintaining
positional integrity yes but I don't
want to do it marshally okay and again
this is the difference from the taichi
energetics is they they will push right
back on the on the line of attack the
angle of attack and just do it
internally. But marshally, no, that's we
don't want to do it. We want to maintain
concentrically the idea of
non-contestation as a guiding principle
for life. Okay? All right. So, as we go,
there's the contestation right there.
You see that?
It's the same thing as when we drive
that shoulder into him into into the
partner on the push. Okay? So again, so
we go that part right there is what we
don't want. So if I I have the internal
skills, he gave yong aspect
and you'll be able to go. But usually
what we do is no spinal displacement,
but there it's there. Do you see the
opposition? Okay. And so it's not
exposed. Okay?
We don't want to do that. Okay? Because
that's when he's getting I'm getting
under you. Do you feel that? Okay, does
that make sense? Okay, so come back out
and we'll use Chris now.
So this hand I yield that way.
This is your yin hand.
If you pay attention to this, there's
two yang hands. Do you see that? And my
universe is concentric with yinyang
theory. I should never have two yong
hands. Two yong hands are right away in
contestation in me and obviously a
contestation in him. So we have to learn
the yin hand.
And this is our outward spiral. So the
elbow is going to move
with my movement out of the way.
He's driving. No.
No. Too late.
Too early. What do I do? I let him push
my hand.
As he's pushing my hand, what I do
though is not that.
As he pushes my hand, I yield to that
push. You see how I'm doing that?
Watch his spine
too young. Do you see his spine?
Is he balanced? Is his line of gravity
in his base of support? The answer is
yes.
What do you think? He's not balanced.
Okay.
So, again, you do this in a fight, the
dude adjust
because he can because he's balanced
balance right away.
How? By non-comontesting
[Music]
the spinal displacement. Okay.
Your angle of articulation
should not change. It will only change
because it got pressed just like the
bulk in yesterday. Remember?
So I have to non-contest.
My angle will not get compromised at all
and it's effortless. Okay. All right.
Let's try it. Yinhand of Kokuho.
The spine is doing the same thing. The
tissue off the spine is doing the same
thing.
Do a slow, steady press.
Don't bend your elbow.
He needs to push, Sean. And you should
have told him that.
[Music]
Okay, let's watch.
I'm not pulling him.
If I were to pull him, which muscle
group am I using? The outer deltoid,
back deltoate. It's very weak. Okay.
I am going to rotate around the
contestation point where we're here.
Then I move my body.
You see that? I don't ever take the
elbow
outside my outer rim.
So because of where I am as the axis of
rotation that is different from this.
This is still in alignment with the
shoulder. Don't pull here. You just went
outside it. Okay.
Boom.
Then
drive with your body.
too late the contestation.
Notice how much
the spine is moving the shoulder, not
the arm moving inside the ball and
socket joint. There's a timing issue to
it.
And it's effortless. Okay, try it.
Don't use that outer back deltoid.
The spine is doing the same as in the
other drills.
Don't Don't move your body. Don't move
your stance. You move your spine.
[Music]
Yes. Yes. Now, and start releasing the
tension just like in the other drill.
You just can't release the spinal
tension. Okay. Which we don't control.
Okay.
There you had a little outer deltoid
there.
He's got he's got a got a push. Okay.
Are you going to pull?
Release the tension.
Okay.
So how in other words how much tension I
feel in zen in here it shouldn't change
because he's attacking me it doesn't
change okay but it's not that okay all
right so pay attention marshially what's
happening when I do the inward spiral
it is already starting to tilt on him
when I take the elbow
and bring it to the inside
as I would on I'm sorry the outward
spiral. It gets that tilt going. Do you
see when you come around like this? No
tilt. No tilt. No tilt. No t. Now I get
a tilt. Do you see that?
What we're trying to do here
is do something to him.
Cut down.
But if you pay attention,
no kazushi, no kazushi, and now you're
going to have to use your lats.
Do you see that?
Instead, I go around the contention
point
until I'm now going in the direction of
the force. Okay? And that is done by
rotating
But getting out of the way,
don't cut down. Let it keep going till I
match its direction.
So I am not cutting his arm down. His
arm is lowering because the kazushi is
lowering his shoulder. So I don't have
to press on his arm.
I just have to tilt his spine
and stay up with his hand. Do you see
that difference? So, I never had even
had to do tricep or lat pressure either.
Boom.
Okay, try it again. It should feel
effortless except for the attentiveness
for your spine.
Keep tilting his spine. Don't cut his
arm down.
Turn your elbow under.
Less less slat. Keep you want your hand
to go that way, not that way. Okay.
Bring your elbow underneath towards your
center line.
Less deltoids.
You keep your spine erect though.
Turn your elbow under. That's it. That's
it.
So,
if I go like that, see there's the
contesting. But if I turn like this,
that's what I want. Then I got to get
out of the way. So that energy that's
coming, that's what I get out of the
way.
No,
got to get out of the way of that. Turn
my elbow down. Okay, try it again. Turn
your elbow down. Get out of the way. You
should end up palm up, not knife edge
down.
Yes. Turn your elbow down. Get out of
the way. Palm up.
Keep your spine strong.
Palm up. Not knife edge down.
Elbow in. Elbow in. Nope.
Elbow in.
Get out of the way. And get out of the
way. Yep.
Good.
Good. Keep your spine. Fix your spine.
Lose the tension.
No. Outer deltoid. Use your torso to
move. Your torso moves.
Keep the shoulder down.
Yep.
Change partners.
There is a groove. You need the groove.
Marially the shape matters. So time
matters. Okay. And so there's a time to
do the elbow has to go down. I have to
heal. There's a time. There's a space
time. My there's a my to everything.
Okay. I can't do whatever. Okay. Go.
Turn the elbow in first. Don't bring the
hand out first. Elbow in and yield. Not
one then the other.
[Music]
Okay, I'm going to exaggerate one point
before we go on.
Is pay attention 12:00 6 o' pay
attention.
Where'd my hand go?
Eight. Okay,
I know you smell it.
Don't go for nine.
Because people regain their balance.
Got it? Keep the This is not the throw.
He's just a weight.
So, I keep this going that way. Okay.
Try it again.
extend him out on that diagonal.
[Music]
So you have to move your torso to eight
and four. Your torso goes to eight and
four.
Your palm is up, not down. Knife edge is
not down.
Move your torso to eight and four.
Not two and 10.
Yes.
Keep your arm
bend the same.
Watch that shoulder tension.
There's a time.
There you go. Watch the shoulder
tension. You're looking for space
because you're late.
All right, here we go.
Marshi, what this allows me to do is I
get out of the way of the line of
attack. Do you see that? So normally,
right, I he stays on the line, I stay on
the line. This this this is crazy. And
again, if you were a cop and the bad guy
did that to you, you would go, "Ah, I'm
losing." Okay? Because you are. But in
iikido, he's on his toes. So now I could
throw him. Do you get what I'm saying?
But if you look, is his line of gravity
inside his base of support? The answer
is yes. Okay? And that's where the root
awakening comes. When you venture out,
they just move. It's not not on his
toes. He lets go. He goes under. He goes
over the top. Okay. So likewise, when I
do this, I'm clearing the line of
attack.
The angle of deflection goes the
opposite way.
Now you can see
what I'm working
with my torso
for koku hole because that is what
throws everything
through the quaw. So watch now I doing
the same movement but it's the qu that's
doing everything. Okay. So yield. I
close the qu over here. He I letting him
pass and I close the claw over here.
I am not using the outer deltoid.
And I'm not using my waist either.
I'm just going like this.
Making it koke hole. I'm training for
koku.
Just push
push push push push.
Push. There you go. Push. Push.
Push. Come on. Push.
You have one goal. There it is. That's
it. That's all you're doing.
Don't You're not falling so high, right?
Notice I'm doing this. Not this. Not
this. Okay, let's fix it. Go. It's
terrible.
Grab and push. Grab and push.
You got to close it again.
[Music]
Grab and push.
Don't turn your waist. Close the quad.
Don't change your elbow articulation.
That's it.
[Music]
Don't change your elbow articulation.
Whoops.
Then close it again. Full range of
motion. It's conditioning.
Oh, elbow bend. Go elbow in. Bring your
elbow in first. Go around the
contestation point
in and around. Yep.
Your elbows bending.
All right.
Once you get him here,
this is where the yong hand comes in. So
his body is going that way,
but I'm going to send his center
that way. Okay, this is your X pattern
without
your base displacement.
When I do this elbow, this hand is
attacking the center. It's the qu that
was closing this. Don't have your hand
pushed. He's still heavy. Okay.
So, my quaw.
So, you I end up here. You see how much
angle and how you can't fit something
there. Okay.
Begin.
Effortless.
Okay, try it. Close and open the claws.
Keep your spine aligned. Go.
Keep extending them to four and eight.
No, we went to three and nine.
[Music]
No, you're at three and nine.
Fix your feet.
One hand is yin, one hand is yang.
Elbows down.
Good. Push her center to me with your
claw.
Good. Change partners.
Hold yourself to the form.
It's not that they're thrown, it's how
they're thrown. That's training.
[Music]
Come over the top.
Good.
Good. Condition
that claw.
Good.
Watch your elbows. Watch your using your
arms.
[Music]
Good.
No need to grab him. Don't waste energy.
Just move the claw.
[Music]
Okay. So, Travis, yesterday we did the
inward the inward spiral, right? He's
driving and we came in. Remember that?
Okay. So, that's what I'm doing right
here.
Don't try to turn him with your hands.
That's not I extend. Let me have you
just body. I extend him then I push
that. Do you get it's a cross that I'm
making. Okay. When I push it though, I
don't use
my arm.
I maintain.
There's his center. I push my claw. You
see how I'm doing that? So, careful
you're not trying to turn him. That's
going to get you in your shoulders.
Outward spiral. Inward spiral.
push.
So when we push,
you can't push and bend your elbows.
Does that make sense?
Yes. You're Yeah. You have to extend
your arms.
There you go. Everyone understand that?
It's very common though. You want to
muscle. He's na
your hair like that.
Push. Good.
Push.
Come on. There you go.
And grab like a snake.
Okay,
this is my conditioning.
Okay, not my arms, not my shoulders. So,
my elbows don't bend. That's the metric.
Don't paint the turn. Yes, he's turning,
but it's two force this way, force that
way from the quad. Okay, here we go.
Let's train, not practice. Go.
Anchor your elbow on the inward spiral.
There you go. From the qua,
get the yin hand more.
Good. Turn that palm up on the yin hand
and come to four to eight.
Yes, Travis. That's it.
And
watch the elbow bend.
Push her center. Push her center this
way.
Extend
[Music]
your arm.
Don't turn them, Rio. The two hands are
not on the same steering wheel.
Yes, that's it.
Good. Now, start. I want you to look. I
want you to train.
Move that. Move that. Okay.
Good. Very nice.
Good.
You got that little bend. So, uh, let's
Derek,
here's where the first reconciliation
is. So, if I go here, I'm going to bend.
So the first reconciliation
is on his grab. I turn it down. So he
has a linear line. I go 90. You see
that? Eventually you'll hit that
contestation point. You see that? But
first this goes yield before he hits
that that shoulder moves.
You see that?
I'm not trying to go around. That's a
contestation there. And I'm not trying
to dominate it. Right on the grab, I
turn it before he hits the shoulder. The
shoulder yields. I go around that. This
is why it's effortless.
What happens?
Which part? The shoulder. Okay.
What happened? The elbow didn't go.
Okay, try
Two hands are doing something different.
[Music]
Change partners.
Get that claw stronger.
elbow.
Two hands are doing something different.
One is yin, one is yang.
Quaqua. Work the cloth.
Push your hands.
Okay. Any uh questions, comments,
observations? Try to bring everything to
the conscious level. Okay. Some of you
felt my technique. You could comment on
that too. Uh you could raise any any
discussion point. The worst thing you
could do is not bring any of this to the
conscious level. Okay.
Uhhuh.
Yeah. So
my coaching again remember I said pay
attention to the instructions that I'm
giving you multiple times and then
quadruple your effort because whatever
you think is what I'm saying is not
quite it. Okay. So the you can watch the
video later was like there's two hands,
one's yin, one's yang. They're not doing
the same thing. Okay. How did this whole
lesson start? two young hands in nor in
normal kokho, right? This keeps their
line of gravity inside their base of
support and you have to muscle and you
contest. And if I go yong yong, we go
yong yong. Okay. So, you're
when you when you go with two, there's
already a yong yong. there's no place
for his spinal displacement to go. Does
that make sense? There was no yin yield
at all in that technique. Usually, it's
not problematic because the UK just
grabs you without the spinal
displacement. Do you see? Um,
we want the contest so that I get
skilled in non-contestation.
We don't I don't really care that he's
thrown. I care how he's thrown. Am I
throwing him with the concentric theory
of the art? Yin matches yang. Do not
contest.
Keep your spine erect.
You should have no tension. You should
have no exertion. Right? So
this has to go somewhere
in his push.
This doesn't let it go somewhere. Okay.
And in your technique, you still have
this is two yongs. I can tell you're
trying to get around it, but it entered
into a yong phase first, and it needs to
enter into that yin phase first. Do you
see that? And then this hand
is not even me
throwing the qua.
Um,
just kind of go ahead a little here. I
wanted you to train the qua because I
want you to bring consciousness to the
qua. Grab, please. So, I had you move
the qua to move him.
What the art actually does
is
brings his mass and his balance here and
he hits that ground path. Does that make
sense? So, it's not that I have to move
the quaw, but there has to be qua
integrity so that when he when I feel
his force, it doesn't spill out around
my spine. But I'm basically throwing him
onto the yong ground path or he's
throwing himself onto the yong ground
path and the technique is a boom and
it's immediate on on touch. Okay. Um
but when you do when you're here like
this, you're always going to have to
push him. you're always going to have to
do something to him as opposed to I get
out of the way and he hits the ground
vector and it projects back into him at
an angle at which his line of gravity is
going to be pushed out of his space of
support. Okay, so your real difficulty
was the yin hand. It is the yin is
always the hardest. Yin is
the seed of non-contestation. So, it's
the most alien to us if you pay
attention. Uh, you almost will never
pull. You almost will never pull in your
contestation. It does happen and it's
still a clash, but it's almost always
pushing and pressing. Do you know what I
mean? Yin is very foreign to us, which
is why
all of your four disciplines, all your
bedrock practices, they're all yin
practices. So take your karma yoga and
your servitude, the practice of
servitude, it's a yin displacement on a
daily basis everywhere you go in life.
Okay? Um why do you say yes to
everything? Um because you're the one
that's going to do the work. You're the
one, no matter how tired you are, you're
the one that's going to do the work.
You're not going to complain. Uh you're
the burden. You're the one up on the
cross, okay? You're not the one down
below kind of stuff. You're on the cross
and you're asking for them to all be
forgiven. This is the ultimate yin
expression. Okay? So, yin has to become
second nature. But at first is the
opposite. You you want your will to
power and you want to do something.
Okay? But this is where that move is
and that is a hard move to get. Okay?
We'll work on it later today. Um,
but as I mentioned earlier, it's the
same thing on the sword. It's in my
yielding that the sword does what it
needs to do naturally and in my
resisting to the yielding in any way
makes that sword do something else.
Okay? Something to the degree that it
won't actually function when someone's
actually trying to do an a tosh on my
weapon. Okay? Remember that point? if
you if it's going to go into your leg
when they when they hit it nice and
hard. Okay. Um
just let take away yin is very hard. Yin
is very important. Um
hence shosin humility do you see the
importance in Buudo training the virtues
all that kind of stuff. Servitude
loyalty filopalty these are all
unselfing practices and behaviors. Um,
and they concentrically are in the art.
Okay.
Uh, all right. Good, good, good, good,
good question. Good point. But that's
what it was. Okay. The young hand is
like, especially here when I'm not
really projecting. I'm just maintaining
integrity that everyone was pretty good
on the young hand. All right. Any other
questions or comments?
Yep.
I think it's probably more coordination
to tell you the truth. Okay. I just
remember the rolling like one side I can
roll better on and then the other side I
I don't roll as good on. That's very
common. I can always throw better with
my right than with my left. Right. I can
write better with my right than my left.
Um
it it'll go away with just the reps.
It'll just go away. Coordination problem
goes away with repetition. Okay?
Especially if you're conscientiously
trying to take tension out of whatever
you're doing because the uncoordination
always is going to manifest with the
unnecessary tension and it's
constipating the motion.
Anything else?
All right.